i've never felt more unsafe
on set
or offset you know
i have never been i've never felt i was
more in danger of dying on the set or on
the drive home because i was exhausted
lane looper was the head of the camera
department on rust working alongside
cinematographer helena hutchins she was
shot dead by the film's star alec
baldwin lane is speaking out now because
he says his friend's death was caused by
cutting costs and cutting corners
this set was unsafe
simply because they didn't have the
wherewithal to
you know follow you know safety rules
that we have in this industry that we've
been following for decades do you
believe that helena's death was
preventable absolutely absolutely
looper resigned from the film on safety
grounds the day before hutchins death
sky news has seen a copy of the letter
he sent to a production manager he warns
of two accidental firearms discharges
and says the filming of gunfights was
played very fast and loose
how will you remember helena for people
who didn't know her what what was she
like she was
approachable she was talented
um she was going places we became
friends really quick and uh
uh
yeah it just hurts to lose a loser
friend like that
in a statement the producers of rust
said mr lupa's allegations around budget
and safety are patently false
safety is always the number one priority
in our films and it's truly awful to see
someone using this tragedy for personal
gain
the police investigation into helena
hutchins death is ongoing one of the
central questions they're considering is
why exactly live ammunition was on a
film set at all
this is a typical pistol that would be
used in a western it's been musing two
to douglas stewart he was one of the
actors on rust seen here with leading
lady francis fisher he had a positive
experience on set the master would open
up the cartridge here but he's now
joining calls for real guns to be banned
on films
for there to be a live round in a gun
handed to an actor
unconscionable unbelievable
uh everybody in my acting community we
were stunned just
couldn't believe it happened
and still can't
those who worked with helena hutchins
say she would have become one of
hollywood's leading cinematographers
they now hope her legacy can be that of
safest sets for cast and crew a legacy
which means a similar tragedy cannot
happen again martha kellner sky news new
mexico